and i don't care where you are in the
world and i don't care
where you're from and we don't care
what you want to do as long as what you
want to do
you truly believe in it hello everyone
hola mis amigos
you're listening to oh my god
hola with me george lopez
phelps
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez oh
my god
omg omg hi oh my god
today on oh my god hi um
we have mr andy vargas who listen i love
people that are talented
clearly you know but i love people that
i respect that have integrity
but something that i'm not
that i always admire people that aren't
is
a good husband a great father
a great partner and a tremendous
love for his family and love for his
friends and that is the guy that's
sitting across from me
mr andy vargas who you will know
in music his dad was a mariachi but also
if you've been over the last few years
to las vegas at the
house of blues that andy is the lead
singer and toured
has toured the world with mr carlos
santana and
we have a special announcement today but
also i just think it's uh one of the
things about doing the podcast is to get
people to know the people that i'm close
to and
in seeing the videos and seeing the
performances
when someone's great on stage a lot of
times they're not
necessarily what you want them to be off
stage but
i got a lot of respect for this brother
right here and
it's awesome to be able to have this
show
and have andy on welcome andy to oh my
god hi dude
all right and george thank you thank you
for all those words man yeah dude
yeah happy to be here man this is
meetings uh andy introduce uh
introduce luke please all right well
ladies and gentlemen we have
luke youngbloom here uh
visiting us from nashville and uh luke
is the
uh the music side to 800-pound gorilla
with cruising street records
and uh you know he's a
he's a wise music business entrepreneur
and uh it's been a uh
awesome to be able to work with him and
and start building
you know what what we have here now um
and this uh you know
in this business venture here uh hey
luke who who was musical in your family
how did the
how did all this become how did it come
about i'm always interested in
how somebody finds the way to their
kind of i wouldn't say career passion
let's say sure sure no that's a great
question yeah i mean
it's funny music was always in my family
my mom actually
uh this is i don't know if anyone will
know what this is but she actually
toured with a a
group called up with people when she was
it was it toured the world
it was they did all sorts of uh
renditions they performed for halftime
shows they performed
with the rockettes i think it's still
going
um but she she did that when she was in
college i don't know if
anyone's familiar with that but if
anybody remembers up with people
they were like
the osmonds times like 10.
they all wore the same outfits and they
sang
songs from that era they were very
uh enthusiastic and they were
all great singers and dancers right luke
right
like that yeah yeah i mean yeah they did
like a ton of billy joel covers
anything that was popular at the time
they would perform these
uh for yeah like sometimes it was school
sometimes it was for theaters and they
would
stay with with host families around the
world they would go globally
and they've maybe performed at the white
house
at any diplomatic uh
probably the united nations anywhere
around the world
they all toured together um
there might be a book that they were a
little bit crazy off off of the up with
people
but you know because it's hard to keep
that many people
like good
because everything the reputation was
like squeaky clean just all-american
beautiful very much sound yeah that's
okay that's very much
that's awesome man yep okay go ahead
yeah that's yeah that's how it started i
mean
that's uh so music was always being
played in the house and then
um yeah over the years it it i wanted to
pursue it and and did the whole
production thing and that's really kind
of how i got started
um i got my degree in music business and
and i got an opportunity um
to go to la this was gosh 10 years ago
now to to run
a small sound department for a small
production company out there and
they would do army training videos and
and
i would do all the sound editing for
these
little you know films and then that
expanded to you know the net
the way anyone would uh moving to a new
city and starting out would be a network
thing
how did somebody come to you and say hey
man um you want to come to l.a and do
this thing like
how who was that person uh
gosh that was so so the company was
called at the time as quest pictures
um and and there was a friend who knew a
friend you know that whole
that whole story that said hey looking
for interns
i went out there about six months they
hired me on to to start running
uh that little sound department and um
i'm actually not sure where they're at
right now but
that led to me getting into more
production yeah
that's some folks out there and that's a
big decision to make because now you
have to leave
where you were from and then come out
here probably try to find a place to
live
try to find a way to exist right do you
you're starting this gig here you're
starting to put things together and it
right it works out for you oh yeah yeah
absolutely
the funny thing is i mean well all of us
know la ain't cheap
so so that was like you know it was a it
was a constant grind and then to be able
to
eventually start making money in the
music business was was really
that that to me was the goal so as
things progressed um
you know it was just a blessing from
there
and then you know uh um you know there's
a lot of people that probably would say
no and not go i don't know
you know i guess it goes back to how
much
you believe in yourself or you believe
in an opportunity like you may believe
in yourself
but also you have to believe in the
opportunity will this opportunity get me
to where i think i
may want to go it's better than what i
got here but then he said coming to los
angeles expensive
and now you're you're kind of starting
on this day one thing right
and then you just start picking things
up start doing those videos
and then what was your next step after
that
yeah so after that i you're absolutely
right i mean
i it that was leading me down a path of
getting into the film
audio side of things which which is
great but i i was being
kind of dragged towards that mixer audio
engineer
uh kind of profession and i was like i
don't know if that's me i really miss
doing the production i i really want to
be the creative
behind creating the project and not
necessarily do the
what i like to call being an audio
doctor right making things sound great
and scrubbing audio files uh you know
all the time so
um anyway yeah so that led into to
production and that's where i started
doing small little gigs and
and um you know i won't bore everyone
with that story but
it propelled me to want to move to
nashville i really liked nashville
i liked uh it was closer to home for me
that was that's michigan
um so it was kind of a balance and i
could see and i could see the industry
growing
right technology's allowed us to work
from anywhere and
back in the day you know you wanted to
do film you had to be in la or or you
wanted or new york right one of the two
now you know nashville is is booming
with more than country
and i saw that growth earlier on and i
wanted to get ahead of that curve
and um and come out here to do
production and and work with
you know pop acts or find that pocket of
of
artists that were doing more than just
country and that and then that led to
working with a entertainment lawyer who
was going to help me start my llc
and that lawyer just so happened to
represent 800 pound gorilla
records and said hey before you do that
how you know we just bought a record
label do you want to
talk to us about running that so um fast
forward
three years here here we are and then
you see the steps right so you see
if he doesn't take the first step he
doesn't get to nashville and then when
he gets to nashville
it's not just country music anymore if
anybody knows what's going on in
nashville
almost every tour manager a lot of rock
stars
a lot of singers incredible musicians at
every bar at every club anywhere you go
during the day
incredible riders incredible opportunity
even at the airport when you land
there'll be somebody singing in the
airport so it's all music over there so
if you're one of if you want to be in
that side of it and the agent side
if you want to be in the music side or
in the creative or in the
you know the nuts and bolts of the
production of it that's a
great place to to be right
so in 2005 800 pound gorilla
when i did america's mexican on hbo we
met in new york
and i sat down with them and i signed
the contract and they and nick's like
you know what at uta now it's like hey
man these guys are coming up they got
this thing they're going to do your
thing they're going to release it
grammy nominations for the
next two dark at chicano america's
mexican
and then i don't really talk to these
guys for a while
and then nick says to me you know you
have a label
as part of your deal with 800-pound
gorilla
and then those guys are now what is it
luke the largest
independent recording company in the
world
yeah from a comedy standpoint yeah uh we
have uh
and i'll speak briefly on for the comedy
side yeah they have over 250 acts now
we're now the record label for kevin
hart's uh
lol we're the record label for netflix
and all their comedy specials
we're actually funny enough for the
record label for atc
um as well so uh we've we've really just
kind of expanded
and and the comedy label uh took off
very fast
and just just with smart leadership and
the team the great team we have there
they they decided hey comedy's doing so
well
but we understand there are so many
different entertainment mediums
outside of comedy where all things
intersect at the end
entertainment is entertainment so they
wanted to break into uh the music
division which is when they brought me
on and then they wanted to break into
podcasting um and they now own uh
uh podcast network in new york and uh
and rights management and in a pictures
division so
they're really expanding into all these
entertainment arms but but it started
with comedy
um and i know george you were such a
huge uh
i i'm speaking for the team but but you
were a huge part of that you were
uh such a big act for for them up front
and i know they appreciate um all of
your
hard work they're great now they're
great so so um
you know uh in talking to luke and
knowing luke and knowing nick
and they say to me you know you have a
you know a music company you have an
opportunity to create a
a music label and then
i say i say well
i like that because you know i
it you know i don't know if it's
it's difficult to do anything successful
i don't know if it's more difficult now
with social media and all the avenues
there
or you know that kind of stuff but i
just know that
it's virtually impossible to take
a good first step like you don't want to
take
five first steps you want to take a good
first step and you know how much
natural ability and you know how much
natural talent
and you know that
however the world turns and whatever
goes on in the world
entertainment singers actors musicians
writers producers that
ball just keeps spinning as people go
out
some people have longer careers some
people don't but it's
always going and it's always giving
opportunity
and then i thought that well
i think i don't think anybody expects me
only to help latinos i would i would
hope that they
wouldn't because i think when i started
i maybe kind of wanted to help latinos
but then
you realize that you can't help anybody
that
doesn't want to do the work because
themselves so when i
when i did my the show the first show
i would say hey listen man let's just do
what's right for the show
and forget about kind of doing favors
or trying to build things
by just having the people be of one
particular color and i said i don't
really think that that's the way that
i'm
i want to do this you know because it's
not the latino community
that fails it would be george lopez that
failed and
you know somehow people think that we're
just part of this one community we're
not we're individuals i think
in trying to help a couple of writers
that were latinos
and latinas they weren't prepared for
the daily grind of going into a place
and writing for
10 12 14 hours a day and being creative
10 12 14 hours a day week after week
month after month year after year
it's very difficult so
there was one writer that was
latino latinx and
and that person would do the crossword
puzzle
when all of the other writers were
working on the script
but the crossword puzzle was in the
script
so if you looked at that person it
looked like they were writing in the
script
but really they were doing a crossword
puzzle because they couldn't contribute
and that person didn't know that all the
other
writers knew that she was doing a
crossword post
wait a minute so that person didn't know
that they knew that
that that person was doing a crossword
puzzle
and after about a couple of weeks of it
when that person came in the morning
all of the scripts had crossword puzzles
in them
every 40 pages of crossword puzzle
so when they sat there to get started
everybody was in on the joke except the
person
who was doing the crossword puzzle so
when they said hey
let's start working turn to page 10 and
that person opened page 10 and it was a
crossword puzzle
but so was 9 and 7 and 6 and 5
and you know it's kind of a cruel
practical joke but it reminds somebody
that
they know when you're not working and
they know when you're
over your head yeah and and for some
people that work that hard
you're not allowed to sit there and do a
crossword puzzle when everybody's
fighting for their
financial uh and their career the show
goes you know that show could have gone
four episodes it could have gone
40 it went 120 and and no other one had
had it so
you know when they would come to me and
they would say you know what should we
do about this person i said hey man
what's
the best for the show and that person
didn't come back
so but cut to now
with the opportunity with 800 pound and
and and
and luke and all the guys and i said you
know i think i might want to do
a record label you know and i think i
might
and you know like andy and i
were i wouldn't say like we called each
other
and we had a lot of respect for each
other when when we would see each other
with carlos
and i remember seeing all the
supernatural videos and
and maria maria and all the smooth
and i was at the super bowl when andy
and carlos santana banned in san diego
played the super bowl and i'm like this
dude is dope man
i mean this guy is a chicano great
singer he looks great
family guy and i called andy and i said
hey man
i got a chance to do this record label
and i think i can get people i can get
their attention
but i want to have somebody there
that knows what it's like to do the hard
work and knows what it's like to give
him
to be given an opportunity and to do the
work and continue to perform at a high
level
so i called andy and and you came on
what was what
what was interesting about it to you and
i was
uh inspired because at the time of my
life
you know i was looking to do something
just like that you know and and uh to
want to help others you know uh
and um uh you know i
i i it's funny because i always thought
that george lopez should have a musical
man you know i i always thought that you
know because
you know uh and you love music and it's
because we know each other well
uh uh you know at the santana shows and
everything and also all the
the work that we do outside you know for
philanthropy you know for your
foundation and everything you know which
you do so amazing
um i just love music man and so it was i
really do i don't think anybody realizes
how much
yeah you know when you play the guitar
well man
you know and you you know if it's okay
to say you know you got up and jammed
with our
with the bands yeah your foundations
event
and so um i just thought i always
thought it was a a no-brainer because uh
you know you know good stuff you know
good music and hard workers
yeah and and so in our conversations
with uh
luke yeah um we found another partner
there
that's willing to go down the road with
us right yeah yeah yeah luke
yeah uh and uh you know um and
you know all the uh 800-pound team uh
that's what we're talking about right
right yeah and um you know
uh we've uh you know we we talk about uh
ideas and and about the future and stuff
and so we're we're building all those
ideas up right now
um but uh but this this opportunity to
uh you know to speak to to everyone
who's out there
watching this here now artists who
you know who have amazing amazing
talents
and who are working you know day and
night because now you could
make all your music from home right you
know and we got some amazing amazing
singers man that are always in vocalist
rappers
you know bands and stuff that are out
there that are just looking for an
opportunity looking for a chance you
know so there's uh
um just uh so we'd like to make the
announcement do you want to make the
announcement though oh man this is
amazing i'm going to make this
announcement yeah so
so we're now starting a collaboration
george lopez
and 800-pound gorilla a new record label
georgia's record label that's called
malas palabras
you know and well it's not just my
record label it's yours it's our brother
well you know what
it belongs to the people to all the
people that's uh you know i'll i'll say
this is because
you know uh uh i i love i love working
with george and his vision and stuff and
i'm here to support
uh you know george and the artists that
we all believe in stuff and with the
help of
luke right there man with your genius
and 800-pound gorilla
over there um you know to be a machine
thank you you know
we'll hear work you know with with the
with the artist and all the things that
that that artists need and
and think about and stuff and and being
an artist man
okay so from this point forward we now
have a record label called ma las
palabras and i don't care where you are
in the world and i don't care where
you're from
and we don't care
what you want to do as long as what you
want to do
you truly believe in it and then we'll
present it and we have a partner
in in luke and we want to find
talented people and allow them and give
them an opportunity to create
their own material to be involved in
their own material
yes but to use our company miles
palabras as a platform
for the young talent of all kinds
to get their start in in this business
and we are
100 behind
the talent you know what i loved about
your vision george was
um how you wanted to support
the artist in their vision and you know
in a day like today
where um and this we really loved um
because 800 pound gorilla was on the
same
page was uh you know in a day like you
know
the music business is it's it's it's
slimy man
you know and um you know uh
we people get you know into bad deals
all the time
and uh you know we uh have been there
man
what are some of the bad what are some
of the bad deals luke would some
one of the bad deals be elvis's manager
colonel tom parker putting
his friends on records that they didn't
write on
and they would get paid on in perpetuity
yeah well yeah i mean i i can't probably
speak for that
specifically let me say allege that let
me say if you're not going to jump in
with me
let me say a ledge so i don't get sued
by you know
colonel tom parker's granddaughters
right
yeah i mean the bad d honestly the bad
deals are where
i think the the most common is what
happens is an artist
is so geeked about i finally get a
record deal i finally get this
opportunity
and they sign their life away they end
up they end up giving up all their
rights
to sometimes they even lose creative
control
where the label starts to you know
basically dictate
who you become as an artist and you've
seen a lot of that change over time
due to the fact like andy mentioned that
you have artists
creating the stuff in their bedrooms and
throwing it out on soundcloud and doing
it completely independently without the
support of a label
that's gotten labels to focus on you
know
how they change these deal structures
and how they approach
an act and you'll still get some of
those deals but i know for our company
we're very much
we never ever look at an artist as like
a money maker necessarily and of course
we have to be in business so it has to
make
financial sense at the same time it's
really a partnership
because if they're not successful
growing their art and being the artist
they want to be and that becomes
something i mean
i always say this uh no matter what to
any artist
at the end of the day you're the one who
has to be the face of it and perform it
right so if you're performing something
you don't believe in that will
eventually show through to the audience
audiences are
they've gotten smarter and smarter so
you want the artist to be genuine to
their art and we want to allow the
artist to do that so we try to stay out
of the creative
what would make it what would make a
young artist just sign something or be
so blinded
by an opportunity that they don't see
maybe down the road
that they're giving away the they might
not even even know
understand what creative control is
right yeah
money yeah i mean yeah andy you could
probably speak to that as well i mean i
i'll
i'll punt it to you being the successful
artist you are no man
what do they see andy what they go blind
i think you know you can look at
something and just
kind of lose all of your
judgment because you think that maybe
signing that paper
you're you're a star but really i think
if you do that
you'd be every anything but that right
yeah well i mean right off the bat you
know sometimes they don't come in with
the right representation
you know some people that they trust to
tell them you know hey
you know i've been here for a while this
is you got to look out for this this and
trust this and then people actually do
hear that information
and they don't care because you know
they see they think the grass is greener
on the other side
and sometimes you know you look at like
the front end thinking that you know
what we got to get past this like back
in the day you'd have to sell
you know you'd have to be like platinum
double platinum to to get back your
you know to recoup you know what i spent
that what you spent on your record start
making a dollar as a matter of fact
you know everyone got paid before the
artist first you know
so um it was harder to make back your to
make back your money and you'd have to
be a really successful artist to really
um to really hit but uh you know what
would make them jump you know especially
you know nowadays just
you know they they don't know you know
it's uh
you think like you know people
pump you up and say you're going to be
big you're going to be big you know and
you're like okay cool
no problem let's go you know let's get
this thing going and then you know you
fall short
you know and so the business today you
know um you really don't need to put
that much into it but you need to really
be focused
right and you need to know where you
know where you're putting your stuff
you know who's behind it you know um
just really you know putting your ducks
in the in order
you know what i'm saying um and uh you
have your best
opportunities like you really can put
see where the dollar goes
right rather than you know just throwing
a bunch of money at something and seeing
what happens you know
what what's been what's been what what
surprised you luke about
having the label and about doing all the
things
what are the things that um
that make you happy that that that say
you know i'm in this business
for the love of this and what do you see
and how does that make you feel when
something goes
um like when something just surprises
you and somebody
hits or they're you find somebody or
what is that what are we looking
yeah no i think the the best feeling
uh i the fir i'll take a step back the
artists we love the most are the artists
that are willing
to step outside the box because
today's day and age is when we get so
many artists coming to us or a lot of
people that want to do this old
traditional method
they get caught in this mindset from the
80s and 90s in the in the early 2000s
that you sign a record deal you get this
big advance
this advance is going to pay for
everything all of a sudden
you know the fame comes right after and
what ends up happening is
uh well i shouldn't say what ends up
happening
that model's gone um essentially right
now it's
tough to get in advance and artists that
are willing to say well what do i need
to do to take advantage of new platforms
social media drives this business so
does technology
the moment apple comes out with a new
product that has this new feature
and opens it to instagram or tick tock
or things like that
you see all these creators all over the
world take advantage of this and then
that drives traffic i mean tick tock is
probably
the number one uh driving social media
platform for the music industry right
now
people are literally launching their
careers off of this stuff
and being open to breaking out so so
answering your question i think when an
artist comes to us and goes
i want a record deal with this kind of
an advance i think that's
you can tell it's it's a older way of
thinking
artists that are like hey i'm willing to
do anything let's do a tick tock
campaign let's do all this stuff to take
advantage of these new mediums that we
can grow this
this you know project of mine or this
brand of mine
what the uh yeah how did how
how does it work in tech how because i
do know that that how does that work
andy and tick tock somebody releasing
some music on tiktok
um well so you know there's songs that
tick tock already have within their
system
right that you like let's say you know
you have song you know
uh song a that goes into the tik tok
system right and then people want to do
a video for it right
so each time they use that song it's
you know the the you know song creators
and
and and the uh composers they get they
get paid
per usage but here's here's a ticket and
and luke you know you can jump on in on
this but
they don't pay after like let's say i
used you know
a song by war right so i use it in my
video that's
one pay right you know so whatever that
goes right but if i go and
all of a sudden my video becomes a hit
low rider or excuse me whoever
war uh they don't get paid each time it
it turns over and that's you know that's
that's not cool
right you know so um if you got you know
let's say
lots of people using that particular
song then you know
now the other place is uh you know if
you're
you know an artist like like dog face
let's just say for example
um you know and and he has you know uh
he's drinking ocean spray you know
sure on his on the skateboard going down
the freeway
well you know then he then you know a
company will come in and sponsor you to
come in and do your
your you know your video right
sponsorship is really where it's at so
you get a fan base you get
you know then you put the little little
sponsored you know tag
you know if you'd like and stuff but uh
but that's that's really where you can
make some money
at it where you know labels can help
support that but there's companies man
that'll that you can pay
that will you know that will come in and
bring a whole production
just for this little tick tock you know
video right and they do this like you
know monthly things so tick tock tick
tock's
big because so many are on it yeah i'll
i'll add to that you please please
that's a perfect example of like that
fleetwood mac song
that comes out that video goes viral
fleetwood mac all of a sudden started
trending on
all the dsp platforms so that's exactly
how the industry is working now where
it's not go sell my record come to my
page listen to my music it's social
media
is driving traffic back to the music
platform okay and
and that's and that's a great example of
it so yeah
yeah so dog face now you know um ocean
spray a little freeway thing does his
thing
he's dancing he's starting to um
does luke know about what dog faces no
no check this out luke check this out
oh well you know their uh dog phases is
working on a
you know a record record himself he's
looking you know to
to to get into you know the business and
stuff and so
um you know they have a i don't know if
we can speak too much on it because i
don't know how much it's you know right
is israel out there but uh but yeah but
he's working on his own music working on
his own music and stuff
and um you know it's definitely you know
interesting you know i heard the track
tracks banging so wherever you know he
does his thing it's going to be
it's going to be dope you know he's got
some a lot of great people
involved behind doing his thing um and
stuff and
and you know it was crazy because you
know i'm getting hip to all of this
you know these videos that are that are
getting big and people are like breaking
i mean before there were demos
you know demos that you had a demo yeah
right and but now they're videos and now
it's you know it's it's this tick tock
audience
you know or that you know social media
audience that becomes the base of your
of of your fan base and then you feed
them and then you can really
go and they can multiply and explode you
know what i mean
um but the way people are getting
people's attention is pretty crazy man
you know like uh billy ellis's brother
you know contacting you know a producer
you know
like through kind of spam you know right
you know when they were kind of making
music in their bedroom
you know what i mean and and so it's
just to get your attention
you know what i mean uh so there's a lot
of
people are really hungry and billy ellis
like that's
almost like what somebody would say
maybe an overnight
sensation or overnight star luke
how did that how did that happen it
seems like that it it always seems that
way i feel like if you
if you dig though she's probably she's
been doing it for a while as far as i
you know i've heard of some of her stuff
but they were remixes right usually you
start with djs doing a remix you put out
a few songs here and then it starts to
snowball but the mainstream absolutely
happened
i think when when they released that
first album whether the things
something in the dark right whatever
that yeah whatever that project
yeah yeah but this is exciting this is
an exciting time by the way shout out to
george too speaking of music
uh i just saw the joyner lucas music
video
and that was awesome that might have
been my favorite
that might have been my favorite rap
video i've seen in a long time okay so
you know if for any i mean everybody
knows i mean but
listen man i'm like 60 year old dude i'm
not really
kind of on the planet like i look at
tick tock mayan
you know my daughter does tick tock
stuff and gets you know paid and found a
partner
in tick tock a writing partner a
creative partner
that's how that's how you can do it and
be successful people will see it
right if it's if it's has potential to
go viral
it'll go viral you can't keep something
that's really good down
because you know you're going to get
eyes on it anyway so
joyner lucas did the video with the
african-american guy
and then the other the the white guy in
that video where they were talking
one spoke in the other spoken i don't
know what the name of the the song is
but it was
really powerful you know so so i
um you know find them on instagram and
send them a
uh dm and say man that was some really
nice stuff you know i appreciate that as
somebody
that looks to make statements and
and things about you know change it's a
it's a tough look at race
and then he hit me back and said hey man
i got this idea
about this whole latino family
and an idea for a song he was doing
eminem was on the song
and he wanted me to be the father in the
video and the song got leaked
so that was gone and then
i think either he hit me back and said
hey man i got this
you know i got this video i want you to
be in
got wahlberg and diddy and you and can i
come on saturday and you know me
on saturday dude man i don't need the
room and i said yeah yeah come on
so he we did it in january and then it
just came out maybe
last three weeks ago and it's fun as
zeem zima and joyner is great and it can
rap
and you know it's millions and millions
of of
views and it's cool for me man i mean
in the outtakes at the end it was it was
fun to do
it was fun to do and um
you know helps me with the kids you know
they see me and i'm what am i mr
electric and then i
bear those chihuahua i think the show so
um
it's great to ride that wave with
somebody who is like a rapper like a
real rapper there's like a real
he's good yeah real hardcore rapper and
being that part but
uh the exciting thing about the three of
us
is getting the message out on
oh my god hi that you have a home here
like you you what's the number call hey
grab what's the number to call
818 5333 1843
818 533 1843
you can leave your what would people
leave their their number their uh
can they perform on the voicemail
whatever
send a video uh on ig
but we're gonna try to find somebody and
we want to make somebody
not as a novelty but somebody that can
have a career in music
yes and and and you know
here we are right now and i'd like to
see it you know in a year i'd like to
have somebody in here that we
saw take the path down the road with
them
and see them get an opportunity to do
to do something incredible yeah that'd
be amazing that'd be amazing
light of someone's absolutely i i would
add uh
i mean for me personally and i think
george you have such an amazing audience
in general
i was gonna throw the question to you
that you threw to me
earlier on which is why music for you
why is music so important to you
and your involvement in and out
throughout the years of your career
well i'm going to tell you and as you
were saying that
like i spent so much time alone growing
up that
if i didn't listen to the radio and if i
didn't have
music around me i'm not sure how
creative i would have been
you know my grandfather was not my
biological grandfather but his nephew
worked at a record
pressing plant in van nuys and he would
bring the secondary
um records that were either
the label was a little bit off or that
had a scratch in the record
or is a little bit tweaked so he brought
songs in the key of life
he brought captain fantastic he brought
marvin gaye stuff he brought kiss he
brought
um he brought bob dylan and steely dan
and he brought every
in the 70s man he brought confunction
this [ __ ] brought i would take
all the [ __ ] mexican records we like
the spanish spanish spanish spanish
spanish spanish
uh muse aquarium stevie wonder spanish
spanish spelling spanish
uh uh uh captain fantastic and a brown
dirt cowboy spanish panda spanish planet
i thought that spanish [ __ ]
i heard enough of it on saturday
mornings to remind me every time i hear
it now i smell [ __ ] lysol because of
my grandmother cleaning the
[ __ ] house but if it wasn't
if it wasn't for that i'm not sure that
i think my
my love of comedy got started in the
love of music
so that's why music still means when
you're alone
it's like your friend and then when you
start to hear the words to songs
and i mean listen man i'm trying to play
this how [ __ ] old i am i'm trying to
play midnight at the oasis on my
[ __ ] guitar
the dude that wrote midnight on the
oasis didn't spend as much time writing
it
as i'm trying to get to at least the the
words of it
you know but when i break it down i'll
i'll come in here and play midnight at
the oasis but nobody's ever heard it's a
great song
but those are the things that you how to
put a song together how to put jokes
together
how to feel like you're not alone play
music how to feel
like you know in 1984 when i was in
indianapolis and just eating at every
show
how to feel like you're not homesick
play low rider on your way up
to to the stage all of those things got
me
to where i am today and that's why you
know it's all a reason why i asked you
why you
came out here that in new york when we
sat down and they said hey man
these guys are going to be big that i
said all right you know and there i am
helped you guys help me
and then here we are uh 16 years later
and now we have milos palabras and we're
gonna find somebody male female young
old doesn't matter
that's talented in music that wants to
be in the music business
and then we all have friends in music
luke you got right
so we're gonna open every door
and every avenue and every person that's
willing to help us help you
to become um what you
whatever you desire to be you can't say
a star but you want longer than that
but to be somebody who's creative and
who's who's
doing music be successful at the
business of it too
you know like educate you know right
right luke
oh 100 yeah i feel like sometimes half
my job is educating the artist on hey
here's
here's something that you need to pay
attention to right and again
you know our company just to reiterate
in in our partnership with with each of
you
really we're just an extension of of
your team
that's that's how we look at ourselves
that again we're not going to be that
label that's going to come in and steer
the ship
say do this do this do this what we can
provide our label services at the end of
the day
we just want the artist to to to create
and be
an artist right the last thing you want
to focus on is how how am i how am i
going to monetize all my stuff how am i
going to collect on here how am i going
to get on this platform how am i going
to get
you know the marketing that goes into
this how do i do a social media campaign
on tick tock
how does all that go together there's so
much business behind just releasing a
project now
and and that's where we come in and so
and support that um but
but to be fair too i mean we we also
like to think differently so instead of
just
a straight hey let's just do a song
let's just do let's just do a
uh an album or ep how can we
how can we think outside the box and
approach this differently
maybe we do a video and a podcast in
conjunction
with the the release of a project all of
these things intersect at the end of the
day
and the more you can touch on these
different avenues in today's world the
more the more you can
really successfully impr impact a
project
well i i think it would be i think it
would be exciting for
anybody to be given that opportunity
because sometimes that's
all that you need i mean when
somebody i'm not going to say the name
because i think anybody knows knows
nobody wanted to help me and
you can't expect anybody to do the work
for you
so when nobody wants to help you you
still have to continue to do the work
going forward you know i just celebrated
42 years
in standup and i would
i would say that without the helping
hand of that one person
if i wasn't ready and even a little bit
beyond ready at that time
that person could have gave me 10
helping hands and it wouldn't have
helped because
whenever the opportunity presents itself
you have to be
you have to be ready like i i did
showcases for
14 months and in the beginning it was no
and that person stayed there with me and
no
and then it started to become yes and
then it's
more yeses but then you know that if you
eat it
one night that maybe the word gets out
that
you know you're you're not what this
person is trying to sell you as
and then i got the president of warner
brothers tv to come and see me and then
we got the president of abc tv to come
and see me
and then they both came on the same
night and then the next day
i had an opportunity to do my own show
and then here we are almost 20 years
later
and it's still on hasn't gone away and
i learned the business of it by doing
the radio
but also like you know i asked what made
you want to go out there to do that job
is every step you take is gonna prepare
you for
a step that you're going to take in the
future maybe whether you realize it
or not and quitting is quitting like you
quit you're out
but even because it's not going to be
easy but even when it's tough
you don't give up maybe you don't you
know entirely devote everything to it
but
at least you're still in it you're still
moving your heart's still beating
and you still love it that eventually
when
you get through the trial by fire trial
by failure trial by
know that if if the
[ __ ] one ray of light
can hit you and you can take that one
ray of light
and turn it into like almost what carlos
would say you turned it into the sun
you'd take a ray and turn it into into a
sun and now
you're starting to do what you need to
do but then you have
the nics and the bangs and the
experience
of what it took to get there and now
you're not
looking for other people for answers you
are prepared to give
your own answers instead of somebody
answering for you
amen which is a little bit tricky when
people talk
for you you know i love uh you know i
love mayan
and i and you know when anna and i were
married ann was very different than
than i was you know ann was a very kind
of control person
all of the time which i'm sure i'll get
in trouble for saying this but
i wasn't like i didn't feel like you
needed to beat people up
to get people to work for you i always
believe that if you are
respectful of their work maybe they're
not the right people then you replace
them
but to just throttle somebody a hundred
percent of the time
and expect them to want to go to work
for you they'll be like man [ __ ] that
dude
because it's just it's just it doesn't
work like that man especially now
you gotta you have to have respect for
everybody you could be disrespectful in
the
record company back in the day but now
but now you can't you have to have
respect for an artist
at whatever level because that person
that
is on tick tock is the star that person
where billy alice's brother
sent a spam email that dominates
the music business and if you're gonna
be the person that's beating people up
you're never going to get back in that
lane where
everything is happening yeah and
sometimes things don't happen
and you just got to know you know give
it your best 100 percent what i
when something doesn't go go through um
my motto is give it your 100 because if
it doesn't go through you
know you gave it a 100 and it wasn't
meant for you
so what's to come so sometimes some
doors have to close for
others to open right you know and just
keep on looking at what's to come
but man you know that's what's exciting
well you know what we're excited luke
man thanks for taking this time and
talking to us but uh
you know you'll be back and as we start
to as we start to kind of
uh get in the weeds and see who's out
there
um absolutely yeah happy to be on thank
you guys for and
thank you andy george nice to nice to
see you finally i know we've talked a
bunch of times
yeah right on brother all right luke
thanks bro thanks guys
uh that's luke our partner in minus
polanos mars palabras
means bad words so we are males palabras
records and get and and get out there
with it so you know i always ask you to
ask
ask luke who was
first i guess you know people would say
how did you know you were funny
how did you when did you realize that
you could sing
because singing is seeing it is singing
is different
you know i i think because your
instrument is your
your soul and your breath
and your i mean this is like the guitar
it's the instrument but your passion
which you can't you have to carry it
with you can't your
your commitment your desire
your pain all comes through
that instrument and when when did
you know because you know people start
singing in church or they start singing
in family get-togethers or they sing you
know on a dare
how did you know that you could sing man
uh you know my my dad was a singer my
dad
was you know a mariachi mariachi singer
so i just
heard it and so i just was always
singing along with him or listening to
all of his records you know going
putting these big style headphones on
sitting next to you know the record
players and stuff and yeah i used to
love those amp
fires you know that were connected with
the you know that you connect the the
you know the record players to because
it sounded so right so real
and uh um i you know it's just kind of
like all i knew
was to be asked to sing at family get
togethers
along with my dad and stuff so um uh i
think
after a while it was uh you know getting
past the the nerves to sing in front of
a larger
audience you know um and once uh
once you know that was done you know
meaning
you know once i started feeling more
comfortable you know i started working
with my dad
and spending those hours after school
you know doing training and exercising
yeah
singing in the mirror all that stuff and
um it's actually
what my dad and i do now with kids you
know we're teaching writing voice and
stuff
so i'm able to pass this on um
but uh uh you know i uh i just
i love to sing i sing in english and
spanish you know it was just natural for
me
just didn't seem sure you know
um and uh you know i would
always you know tell my mom i'm gonna
leave you know when i get upset i'm
i'm out of here i'm going to l.a i'm
going to follow my dreams and you know
uh and so she knew that i was on a path
you know to
to go do something and uh you know it's
so funny because i had a there was a guy
that was across the street
um that would come and visit his aunt
and he was and he worked for sony man
you know and uh and i'd always i was
talking i would talk to him and talk to
him all the time i'd go over and i'd
leave messages
you know on the door you know and i was
like you know
like 14 at the time you know so my mom
knew i was i was um but that's
crazy man so your dad's a mariachi
you're singing with your dad
you're getting over your nerves you're
working on stuff
and then the dude that goes and visits
the person across the street
works for sony yeah i mean incredible
yeah yeah i mean i you know my story um
was a
you know i i sang in a little group
around town
as well in high school yeah you know we
had we used to go inside instead of uh
well i played football as well but we go
to the football field at lunch
and sing like you know the you know four
latinos singing like harmonies and stuff
yeah at the football field
yeah and my cousin uh ben he was a a
producer and he made beats so he was
sampling beats we'd always go over to
his house like every night late night
make beats and
and sing you know little demo sets and
stuff um
and uh you know learning learning music
learning chords and
um and then i had it and i had an
opportunity
my mom out of all people i wanted to
take it a step further my mom
works at wells fargo bank right yeah you
know bless her heart she's still
committed she's a manager and uh um
she her you know regional manager
worked with the guy in the music
business and he just had a
hit called kokomo you know the beach
boys
yeah yeah so he produced like 89 88 89.
uh terry melcher produced that song and
so you know terry gave me a
an opportunity to go in and he goes yeah
man i got this you know new studio over
here and and
it was like when pro tools was just
kicking off you know yeah
and stuff and so i worked you know i
went over there and started recording
some demos for him and bruce johnston of
the beach boys you know
it's interesting how we got a little and
terry melcher
for bobby lee if he's listening all the
crime aficionados
oh yeah so brian so
dennis wilson is driving in
can i say this yeah i mean
it's fat it's fact i don't make you
uncomfortable but
dennis wilson from the beach boys is
driving picks up some hitchhikers
takes them to their house they're manson
followers and then
uh dennis wilson meets charles manson
but they're kind of taking over his
house and they're in their eating and
they're
doing stuff and then charles madsen
comes over and he's playing the guitar
and dennis introduces him to terry
melcher and terry melcher says like
this [ __ ] is awful this [ __ ]
guy is horrible
and in front of manson because i guess
that's you know
that's what was going on and
i think when terry melcher testified in
in the trial against charles manson if
you look at
what's out there in documentaries that
you know
manson wasn't a big dude but an imposing
and you
know what went down that they even said
that terry melcher was just
you know he's he's a music producer you
know they're they're
they're sensitive dudes you know they're
they're creators
and that he looks scared coming in he
looks scared on the stand never looked
at him
and left and terry melcher beyond that
was doris day's son
was never really looking to be um
known or be seen like that that night in
69 and august 6 that changed
everything including the path of music
because then he used helter skelter as
the song for that it changed i don't
think a song had been associated with
a heinous crime before and at that time
the revolts
vietnam there's a great um
series of dr series on apple tv called
1971 that had like
the sla and patty hearst they have
marvin gaye and the vietnam war
and and really all about the music and
the music was about the times
black panthers and angela davis my
grandma was afraid angela davis my
grandmother listen my grandmother
lived in mission hill san fernando if i
mentioned angela davis my grandmother
would would freak out angela's david was
in oakland
and she's still around angela davis i
was trying to get a hold of her and tell
her that you know
out of respect for her i think what she
was able to do
and create an awareness for you know
racial uh situations but
if i would say to my grandmother give me
a ride to school i'm not going to direct
you i'm a talented davis okay get in the
car
so so um
it's interesting how even your mom at
the bank
and terry mills miller at the bank like
all of those
things presented themselves a guy from
sony across the street yeah
um and then your mom worked at the bank
of terry melcher
and what was the first bit of
like a break of sunlight that you got
that you said okay i could
i could be i could be taking the trip
here
well uh let's see so you know the some
of the demos that we recorded with
with terry and by the way he he was we
never spoke of any of that stuff
ever and that the long time that i knew
him and uh he always took care of me man
you know always took care of me and
treated me like like another
you know that's amazing you know and
sometimes you'd be like oh yeah i forgot
man you're you know you're
you're you're 14 turning 15. i forgot
you got to eat you got you eat more than
we do
yeah yeah you're right uh so um anyways
uh
uh we passed it uh one of our demos
around
you know to some people in la and uh
someone
named ron fair heard it you know and and
uh
um and he you know he's from rca at the
time rca bmg
and they came and drove to carmel and
terry you know just to
you know the heart that he was he put
everybody up he had a hotel out there
and
called the cypressin carmel and we used
to stay there all the time it's
beautiful beautiful
uh place and so we put a brand there
and uh you know everything started for
me you know then and then you know
later on um you know i i learned the
music business at that time
studios production you know and i loved
that time because you know pro tools
was was really starting to really kick
off inside of studios and it was kicking
over tape you know
and then they uh you know the big
studios were using you know pro tools
and tape
you know at the same time you know so
pro tools would do all the vocals and
then you know they would record the
stuff and then they would print the tape
to get that tape
sound you know um but i would just sit
there like
you know i was watching our engineer and
like i never leave when he left i would
i would go you know because i wanted to
you know sure learn it all
i was just intrigued but uh um you know
so
some time goes by and and and i i moved
to la uh
and uh i moved you know i kind of uh
joke with my with my
folks and you know because uh we say you
know andy went to the university of bmg
sure you know uh and because there's you
know you read those books
you know and says well you you either
you know you study you go out you study
the you know the music business or you
jump right in and you just burn it and
you do it but i think you know
uh now you really gotta know it well and
and and study it well as you go along
um because god knows you know i've been
in so many
you know difficult times difficult
situations and stuff you know that you
know thank god
you know i'm able to you know uh to be
here now and i've had so many amazing
mentors in my life george i'm just so
grateful you being
one you know so grateful for you man um
and also
you know someone who came into my life
and just changed my life was carlos
santana
right you know um and uh you know
it was interesting because i had
recorded my version of oyakomova
you know and we had
approached with the label we approached
carlos and stuff and he was working
on the beginnings of supernatural and
all of that
and uh um you know it was
just not the right timing for it you
know but you know
that god had another plan for me and uh
you know an opportunity came to audition
for you know the supernatural tour
and uh you know that's history
you know uh you know joined i came in
and uh you know i told you this
you know carlos is like well so what do
you want to do he's
sitting on single song so he gives me
the mic and he starts playing smooth you
know
right yeah yeah that's how that all
started and you've been with him for how
long um
so about about 21 years wow
so people that see you you know i'll go
down to see you guys in vegas because
you know i did the same thing with kobe
bryant when kobe bryant
was uh you know the 20 years he was with
the lakers um
uh knowing him before he got married and
knowing him uh
all you know through his life that
when somebody is that special
you think i'm gonna watch this person
perform
as much as i can because
it's just somebody's that good and
that was the first person that
i felt that towards and then meeting
santana and then becoming
really really tight with them as like
brothers and
same thing with truvino that i go see
carlos just
because i feel like it in albuquerque or
i saw you guys in jones beach
with the doobie brothers or in vegas
multiple times
or wherever but like that guy
has always welcomed me as a mentor as
well so
you know when you see a guy that's been
around since
before woodstock and is still viable and
creating music and
is even more needed now
that you know that a kid that is playing
the guitar in the streets of tijuana can
grow up
and become that guy with a pure heart
and a wonderful soul and encouraging and
mentor
me and you that milos palmer's records
just make sense on the way that
you know an opportunity was presented to
me in music that i love
and we're going to try to you know
through all of our
knowledge and some of the things that
that you know i'll learn
but nothing would make me happier than
to make
this company work with you
and know that carlos is just a phone
call away
oh yeah you know and that those guys
that you know luke and
everybody that yeah when you get a
when you get a bite that we can i think
we can bring in
um some artists that uh
that could break well without a doubt
yeah
with without a doubt yeah and uh and
cindy
yeah and cindy as well yeah and cindy um
yeah but all right man good all right we
did it um
818 what is it again
eight one eight five three three
eighteen forty three thank you yeah
thank you everybody for listening and
watching and i got high
you